now to some key numbers as the president
blitzes the battlegrounds the real clear
politics average of polls
has him trailing biden in michigan and
wisconsin
by nine points and five points
respectively as you can see on the
screen biden also ahead in nebraska's
congressional district
two by uh congressional district two i
should say by
seven points that it is considered a
toss-up and it's where the president is
heading today
let's uh bring in tim murtagh trump 2020
communications director
tim great to have you here this morning
we of course have a lot of questions but
first what is the mood of the campaign
seven days out
especially after i just read through
those polls there
well the mood is fantastic we are
definitely upbeat and very cautiously
optimistic that the president is headed
for re-election
we know what's going on in these
battleground states from our own
internal data
and we know that in the states that are
going to make the difference states like
florida and pennsylvania and michigan
and wisconsin the president remains
strong and is headed
quite clearly to re-election if you're
looking at these public polls and even
the average it's just a bunch of
averages of flawed polls
the national news media has spent four
years trying to destroy
and defeat president trump and so i
don't know why
anyone would put any stock at all in
polls
paid for by those exact same media
organizations of course they're going to
produce numbers
which confirm their own world view and
then you take the average
it's just an average of all those bad
stuff so i get that you're going to
dismiss we know what's real
i get that you're dismissing the polls
as we've often heard from the campaign
um that there are real numbers that we
can look at including some of the
positivity rates in these states that
the president is visiting today where
coronavirus is still a very
real concern and joe biden
is still strongly polling above the
president when it comes to who would
handle
the pandemic better in michigan ohio
pennsylvania and wisconsin
tim wisconsin's positivity rate seven
day moving average
28 nebraska 22
in wisconsin it's up 53 over the last
two weeks
positive cases this morning the ap is
writing worst place worst time trump
faces virus spike
in the midwest as he heads to these
states so why talk about the lockdowns
rather than battling the virus itself
when he addresses voters there
well the president is battling the virus
itself and this is another area where
there's a clear contrast between the two
trump and biden president trump wants to
he wants people to be safe and take
precautions but he also knows that we
cannot let the virus just lock us down
again
he has been in a nine-month battle
against the virus
and has posted a whole bunch of
victories and a lot of good news
the production of ppe and masks now the
the development of
the therapeutics rem deserve being
approved by the fda
we are this close from getting a vaccine
approved and for distribution and it
would go first in 100 million doses to
our most vulnerable populations
contrast that with joe biden who is
clearly the candidate of
lockdowns he talked about how we're
facing a dark
winter that is not an optimistic message
if you're talking about locking people
down again
for how long six months a year 18 months
remember in china
they welded people into their homes i
mean does he recommend a similar style
approach
i don't know okay if you head the
country towards another lockdown
lock the economy down it would be
devastating to people maybe if you're
talking about salary
or if you can work from home you can you
can get by with that but you cannot
survive
if you are in the service industry if
you work with your hands you can't stay
locked up in your house
for another prolonged period and joe
biden is offering
exactly that and that message does
resonate with some voters obviously who
are restricted by these shutdowns
but joe biden sees a serious opportunity
here here with joe biden yesterday
really taking on the president and his
coveted response listen
saturday donald trump said that cobra 19
count was
wasn't really going up everything was
leveling out
he suggested the doctors were inflating
the numbers
catch this because doctors get
more money what in the hell is the
matter with this man
it's is this message working for joe
biden
uh no and it shouldn't because this is
the same joe biden that we know would
not have restricted travel from china
like president trump did because he
called it xenophobic
and fear-mongering and so we know with
certainty
that we would be in a far worse position
today as a country
if joe biden had been president at that
time and joe biden look
throughout all of this joe biden has
been completely unburdened
by the responsibility of leadership
every minute
of this crisis he has taken the
coronavirus and turned it into a
political
weapon even to the point of trying to
scare people away
from taking the life-saving vaccine when
it is ready and approved and on the
market for people
to get which by the way people will be
receiving for free
under the trump administration he spends
all of his time
trying to frighten people away from
taking the vaccine that is
reckless it's taking something that is
so important to saving lives
making people afraid of it that is that
is endangering people's lives
simply to score political points it's
reckless and irresponsible i want to
leave that there and i want to head to
immigration now here was the president
yesterday talking about the border
we're going to defend our borders they
don't want to have borders they want to
have open borders
we just hit 400 miles of war
and this is a wall that's exactly what
border patrol
and all of the law enforcement people
wanted where
is the messaging when it comes to
immigration the border the wall
it dominated the 2016 trump campaign
tim and here's a headline in the wall
street journal front page this morning
trump campaign tones down immigration
messages that dominated
2016 election it says the issue
barely makes the top 10 list of topics
highlighted in political tv
ads it was a wall street journal review
that found
it was the fourth most mentioned issue
in his 2016 campaign but has barely
cracked
the top 10 this cycle around was that a
concerted
effort to transition away from that
topic that
did so well for the president in 2016
tim
no and as a matter of fact the sound
bite from the president you just played
proves that that's not the case the
president still talks about this issue
at every single rally just about
and it sets up a very clear contrast yet
again
no one can mistake that president trump
is the candidate who will enforce our
borders enforce our immigration laws
protect american workers and commun keep
our community safe
by opposing sanctuary cities as well joe
biden on the other hand
promises an open borders policy he said
for the first hundred days if he's
elected he won't deport
anybody anybody and then after a hundred
days he would deport
only those illegal aliens who had
committed felonies he would grant
amnesty to
11 million illegal aliens give them all
taxpayer-funded health care
and provide them work permits so they
can compete with americans for jobs that
they need coming out of the coronavirus
crisis
on top of that joe biden will support
sanctuary cities which is a slap in the
face
of these communities and people in those
towns and cities
who want safe streets it is absolutely
still a big issue and it's no wonder
that some parts of the media want to say
it's being taken away as an issue
but the president talks about it all the
time and we'll continue to i'm running
out of time i have so many things i want
to ask you about but when it comes to
the economy axios ran a headline
on the front page of their website this
week that president trump does not have
a plan on the economy he talks about a
big beautiful tax cut but but it's but
we haven't really got
real details from the campaign will we
hear more in the coming days will he get
more specific
about those tax cuts and what his plan
is to do to get us
out of this rut that we're in due to the
pandemic
voters know that the president built the
world's best economy once and is already
doing it a second time
his approach has always been to keep
taxes low
allow people to make more decisions for
themselves about how to spend their
own money that they've earned keep
regulations low get government
out of the way of entrepreneurs get
government out of the way of farmers so
farmers can thrive
what do you have on the other side you
have joe biden the president said it
at the top of this scenario main place
what does that tax cut look like
what is the specifics i will i will let
as you know
the campaign doesn't write legislation
the president's goal is to keep taxes
low he has talked about further cutting
taxes for the middle class he has
often talked about allowing people to
keep more of what they earn
making it cheaper for businesses to hire
people and look at what joe biden is
offering
raising the corporate tax rate that'll
make it more expensive
to do business in the united states than
it is in china
another case of joe biden looking out
for china ahead of american workers
plus raising taxes by four trillion
dollars
if your question is who's better on the
economy
we welcome and in fact we are dying for
that argument
because it is quite clearly president
trump and it's not even close even the
bad public polls show that
president trump is the leader on the
economy he built the world's best
economy once
he's already doing it a second time joe
biden is a disaster
voting for now i've got to leave it
there about china we're out of time but
please come back soon
thank you